see they're they're breaking down george
square george oh yeah we'll pull that up
let's do that yeah talk about that
the chop wait what happened they're
pulling down that memorial george floyd
memorial
where there's like 12 city blocks where
they like blocked off um from the road
no no no
it's okay here we go is this bunk uh
it's not bonk it's just you're you're
late to the party
yeah so cbs4 minnesota says george floyd
square intersection briefly reopened
before
community pushback you know man
are we still on the air okay i'm not
gonna swear i was gonna swear if it was
disconnected uh i'm glad we're not
disconnected the media is such trash
community pushback what's that mean the
community has been begging for the
police to come in and stop the rampant
gunfire and like killings
in the no-go zone in minneapolis the
community pushback i love how they call
it george floyd square
is that is that it like okay so in
memory
of george floyd you have a bunch of
people shooting each other and shooting
at buildings and stealing cars and
there's like reporters hitting the deck
wonderful that's a great memorial so uh
as they they did reopen it was big news
everyone's like oh
the no-go zone's being shut down the
cops are moving in and like an hour
later antifa came and just put it all
back
oh and then they'd come back again to
take it down again
no that's it they gave up oh yeah the
police are are you know incapable of
doing anything
dang well they can arrest you yeah you
know for at a moment's notice based on
government uh government edict
yeah but not anti-vote based on the
actual law yeah so i had a qui i have a
question about this you know let me ask
you a question
so uh uh uh sheamus what would you call
it
if a group of people of an ideology
they they uh uh believe your nation's
history is fake
and they begin imposing their ideology
over this people they fly a different
flag
they burn the flag of the one nation
they start seizing territory in certain
cities
where people are literally shot and
killed and they get
they get the law enforcement to operate
based on their whims
and edict instead of the actual law
those that literally break
hard law are exempt from it and those
who violate edict
get arrested and put in jail meanwhile
prisoners are being released
and then they then fly their flag at
your embassy like what would you call
that
mostly peaceful mostly peaceful mostly
peaceful yeah i think that's probably a
solid situation you add all those things
together isn't that wrong with that tim
they're protesting a bad thing
so anything they do is okay and if you
criticize any of that you're just okay
with the bad thing that they're probably
let's go through this uh let's go let's
literally go through each point first
antifa openly breaks the law and the
da's release them
actual statutory law that is codified
yep
conservatives and people and and you
know not necessarily even conservative
small business owners
violate edict from governors that is not
codified and they get arrested by police
and fined
yep okay antifa begins seizing
different jurisdictions of different
cities with weapons
and even killing people on numerous
occasions
these people say that the history of
this nation is incorrect
everyone of this this nation is evil and
they burn and desecrate the flag
of this nation and then they fly their
own flag
with marxist symbols at the embassies of
this nation
that doesn't it's it sounds like uh like
in like
insurrection like occupation like like
insurrection like a group of people
telling you your history is wrong and
burning your flag
like you're flying their flag at your
embassy if it was the chinese government
i hate
i don't want to like make the chinese
bad guys you know whatever but if it was
like a foreign powers government that
was doing this to our country
that's that that would be like an
occupation and creating like a puppet
state
out of our government yep if they can
decide who
who is or isn't guilty of the crimes but
it was like the chinese government or
the
sovereign government was deciding that's
in west virginia there's a huge
controversy happening because
at the schools the people who are uh
who got elected are woke and they're
introducing critical race theory
but the people of west virginia are all
like seriously not woke
unbelievable so there's like i i thought
i was going to come spend some time out
here but i can't
but it's it's crazy when you think about
it because
you have the police enforcing things
that are not laws and a lot so that
during during the pandemic they started
releasing prisoners
and they started putting they arrested
that salon owner and it was crazy it was
like you're putting a salon owner in
jail and releasing
criminals she didn't break any laws she
violated an edict
the governor you know like we hereby
decree and she gets arrested
she gets arrested and locked up you look
at the barber in in michigan broke no
law
violated the decree of a governor yeah
dude if when a group of people come to
you and say your history is fake
and they demand you revise your history
and they go into your schools
telling your kids that their history is
wrong and that
the the you know the people who run this
country are evil the founding fathers
are evil
the the country is an evil nation that
must be you know broken up or broken
apart
they burn the flag the police help them
i'm like that's it like america what is
it is it still a thing at this point
when the history of this country has
been erased as the country still exists
is there an america if the history of
america is gone it's an interesting
question i mean we talked about this
before but the cities are definitely
gone i would say
go out to the country get away from them
you've been saying that a lot too
i think it's possible that this country
could just end up fracturing
i see secession being a possibility that
sounds kind of insane i think if you
said that five years ago people would
look at you funny
and i'm not saying it's a certainty but
it certainly seems possible at this
point
and i think maybe that could be the only
peaceful solution
maybe again and i'm also mostly peaceful
i'm also more or less thinking out loud
here i'm not making hard
and fast predictions but i think you
could still have a country i think it's
just that these cities end up falling to
these
far less actives or what happens is
after some time people realize how
horrible things have gotten in the areas
where these activists have basically
been put in charge by the political
authorities
and they they react against it
i just i just see it for people who burn
the american flag and now they're flying
their flag at our embassy
for sure for sure i guess my point is i
i think there's going to be a massive
backlash against it
i don't no no i think conservatives are
particularly ineffective
yes so i agree that conservatives are
but i think a lot of the people who buy
into this stuff right now
are starting to see it fall apart and
the more power we give them
the more they're going to be exposed is
completely incompetent
even evil to their followers i
but it's tribalism maybe i mean i think
it's tribalism but like at some point
you know when you're not getting fed you
kind of stop believing in whatever it is
the people who are in charge of you are
telling you the narrative
except one faction is saying we'll give
you everything for free and it's those
evil evil people keeping it from you
so when things break down they're going
to look at two factions the republicans
being like work hard
and then they're going to look at the
democrats being like we'll give you
whatever you want
and what where are they going to flock
to i guess depends on how things
actually become divided in terms of the
actual authority
if you look at these left-wing cities
where people are protesting and they're
getting away with doing whatever they
want and they're
essentially in charge to some extent
like you've said they basically can run
wild and do as they please
i think it's going to become obvious
even with people in these movements that
yes
they and their leadership are in charge
or they do have special privileges
they're in control of the situation
and when there's a failure it's pretty
much their fault i think it's going to
become more and more difficult to
scapegoat the republicans who are out in
the country when your city is falling
apart and it has
totally democratic leadership the the
progressive in pennsylvania and
philadelphia got reelected in a
landslide
30 points yes i'm not saying it happens
today or tomorrow but i'm saying i think
in the long run corrupt hierarchies fall
apart
maybe you know but after everything we
saw last year
people went out in droves desperate to
vote for democrats
yeah like ted wheeler gets reelected
they everyone hated him even the left
hated him
and he still gets reelected and then you
look at minnesota and you look what they
did with the chauvin trial
i mean dude i have zero faith
that this country like i look at
everything that's happening and i'm like
the people who are ignoring it they're
gonna wake up one day not realize
what happened or how it happened because
when you're watching it happen in real
time
you can it's just crazy but it's really
funny
when i when i talk to somebody who's not
who doesn't pay attention to the news
and they still think it's 2019. they're
like man last year was crazy huh
and then i'll be like what about it was
crazy and they'll be like you know just
a pandemic on a lockdown
and you can ask them anything about the
stimulus the inflation the shortages the
pipeline attacks
you could talk to them about china and
taiwan also be like what
it's really crazy when i look someone in
the eyes and i'm like yes what did you
think about like
you know they're flying blm flags that
are embassies and they go what
yeah i'm like what like it's it's insane
how
cause it's imagine this if imagine if
right now
you hear this stuff and then you should
turn the news off
and the next time i see you i'll be like
so did you report to your
gulag for uh reassignment for for
education for gender reassignment
they'd be they'd be like what are you
talking about it's like oh yeah
education starts tomorrow and they're
like what do you what that's that's not
real how can that be real
and it's and it's been this way
throughout the culture war when i talk
to people who don't follow news
i'll say something and they'll just be
like that's not true how is that
possible
yeah because it's happening faster and
faster and faster
so we're at this point now where let's
talk about uh well the state of this
country
a year of riots and explosions and
vandalism and chaos in the pacific
northwest
the no-go zones being set up where
people are taking them over with guns
and killing people literally killing
them in the george floyd no go zone
in the capitol hill no go zone people
literally being shot and killed in
portland air and dance and getting shot
in the chest
then you look at the trial of chauvin
and what happens not only does he get
charged by the state the feds come in
after the fact and the feds had a secret
plan to arrest him should he have been
acquitted
and now they're charging him again with
civil rights violations and the three
other cops
when he was being tried the jury had to
be escorted in
with armed security because the city was
under a riot
so you know that's not a fair trial 100
like i said the embassy is flying the
flags of this ideology
joe biden a ton of trump policies on
banning the ideology
it really does feel like if you took
someone from two years ago
and brought them to today they would not
believe a word you would say about the
current state of the country
and believe it or not many people still
don't think antifa exists well you know
and this is the thing so
when people were talking about the far
left
for for the past several years we were
more or less scoffed at
as not serious because this is just a
bunch of young dumb college students
and teenager young adult activists no
one actually cares they don't have any
actual power and look at where they are
now
everywhere yeah 16 year olds are 19 year
olds now yeah
yeah and the 18 year olds are you know
in their 20s
and the people in their 20s are now
entering their so it's funny ten years
ago
you know when we started we started
getting the culture war stuff gamergate
i think was what like 2013 2014 that was
2014 yeah 2014. so now it's been seven
years
it's crazy so somebody who is 15 during
that
is now 22 they're now taking jobs at
industry
somebody who was 20 during that and
working for the woke is now 27
and a manager at a news outlet some some
like senior editor
and they're writing stories in favor of
that ideology this is why i was telling
people years ago
it's this civil war like the collapse is
going to get crazy
when you see people fleeing red
blue states to red states to get away
from this and people in red states who
are urban centers who are more blue
fling the blue states and the
polarization is sharpening
between um physical boundaries
like what's the what's the what's the
result of this joe biden's flopping
around like a lunatic
the border crisis is worse than it's
ever been kamala harris laughs at the
prospect
and what happens come 2024 does donald
trump run again and get re-elected
is there the backlash do you describe
where people are like i can't i can't
handle this anymore
so they vote for donald trump and then
this causes an equal and opposite
reaction on the left where they go nuts
and start destroying things
i don't know i really don't know i think
it's possible when i'm when i'm speaking
about um
a reaction and part i was sort of
talking about like a hypothetical
scenario where the nation actually does
collapse
um in terms of trump being reelected in
2024
i mean i think there's certainly a
possibility of that happening i think
there could be backlash i think it'll
become really obvious by that point that
this is a complete farce everything the
left has said they want is pretty much
just
them paying lip service to a specific
set of values that seemed popular
so that they can get power and basically
tear down the institutions that they
harbor resentment towards for whatever
reason but they're doing it on opposed
yeah i just i think that it's
possible at the on the other hand i
don't know i think
the entire dominant media culture is on
their side
and that's no small thing i think many
americans don't trust the media
anymore but some still do and also these
people are in control of the social
media outlets as well and so they
determine what's true and false and the
fact checkers will say x y and z if it
fits their
agenda and so it's hard for me to say
i can't say right now that there will
absolutely be this backlash by 2024 and
that donald trump will be re-elected
but i do think that it's a distinct
possibility there are a lot of factors
here and it's too complicated to make
one
prediction i want to sort of see how
things go especially because look
if you had asked me one year or less
than one year into trump's presidency
what i thought the end of his first term
would look like none of my predictions
would have come remotely close to what
ended up happening
and so right now we're less than a year
in a biden's president i'm supposed
presidency and i'm kind of sitting here
trying to make a prediction
on whether trump could be re-elected by
2024 if things will get bad enough
i mean i really can't we just have to
expect the unexpected at this point and
pray
i mean that's my only advice i don't
know if he'll get reelected i mean it
might be a buchanan situation you know
joe biden flounders and then
trump gets reelected and then civil war
or whatever thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you